[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum
good morning good afternoon i uh
uh it was you know a crazy week fun week
uh last week we saw this movie nobody uh
my buddy bob odenkirk he facetimed a
group i
i rented a theater you went with me ryan
i did
i rented a theater at city walk it was
you know like 300 bucks 350 bucks and
had like 15 friends that were all
vaccinated and we went and uh
watched this movie nobody which i really
enjoyed didn't you it was
great it really was fun yeah uh it was
fun to be in a theater again
it was fun to be in a fit because uh
amanda and i had seen that when it came
out on like on demand
and so you liked it enough that you
wanted to see it again because it's much
more fun that way because this was like
it's like john it's john wick yeah it's
an action
movie and you need to sort of the
audience reactions to throats getting
ripped out or stepped on
yeah it's kind of necessary it was fun i
had a a real good time um
my buddy harlan williams was with me and
a bunch of uh other friends but harland
uh you know from dumb and dumber you
know
you drinking on some of grandpa's cough
medicine are you there buddy
um but he was just commentating the
whole time which was funny because every
time
christopher lloyd came on he'd go great
scott
you know back to the future play doc uh
and everybody was just fun to be with a
group of friends and laughing and having
popcorn and
i really enjoyed it that was nice i
really want to thank kiefer sutherland
and jason patrick for last week's
episode that was
it went viral and if you haven't seen
that one i think you're going to want to
see it uh
they really opened up and i've got a lot
of people
emailing me and texting me and tweeting
me that they really love the episode a
lot
and also john glover who played my
father in smallville he's
you know michael uh you know um his
partner adam who never really
compliments anybody
says that interview was the best dinner
you
you've ever done and then somebody
called me and said you know it was the
best interview uh close friend of kiefer
said it was the best interview and i
it just means a [ __ ] ton man i'm like
really i always feel awkward i never
watch him i feel like i look like a dork
and i'm like
you know i feel like a kid asking these
questions and uh overall but look it's
you know i'm really happy with the
episodes and and
i commend ryan here for great editing
and bryce and
and for producing but thank you for if
you haven't checked out
kiefer and jason patrick i think you
should yeah
everyone was excited that you broke sort
of uh
like a 30 year old story really i broke
a 30 year old story of uh
apparently the divorce the the the
breakup with
kiefer and julia roberts and then julia
roberts taking off to
ireland with uh with jason patrick and
they're both sitting in the same room
talking about this and they're still
close friends but i urge you to watch
the episode it's uh
it's good to see these guys together um
so thank you
for listening um also just want to say
thanks to hint water they don't they
just give me water they don't give me
money or anything but
i'm always drinking hint water so thanks
han thanks red bull for keeping me awake
i don't drink a lot of red bull but when
i do
i apparently need it that's the dos
equis slogan though
what is it i don't always drink beer but
when i do i prefer to sex i don't always
drink beer but when i do
well i don't know that thank you guys
for for watching the
watching or listening to the podcast
again you know it's important if you're
if you're here for erica christensen who
i love and adore
i urge you to subscribe to the podcast
and listen to other people you'll learn
something hopefully i learned something
every episode
and follow us on twitter and instagram
uh
at insideau podcast on instagram and
facebook
you can follow us and at inside you pod
on the twitter
and if you want to subscribe you could
subscribe on youtube
ryan uh uh youtube.com slash inside of
you with michael rosenbaum
and if you want and you can also
subscribe on apple and spotify and what
else a lot of stuff
stitcher probably yeah there's a lot of
places so i urge you to do that write a
review
keep this show going thank you uh
westwood one thank you
everyone who listens all my patrons
thank you for the support and the love
and if you want to join patreon um it's
a wonderful uh
place to be it's uh you know for folks
that love the podcast they subscribe
uh to the patreon you get a lot of perks
there's a lot of fun stuff on there
there's
there's tears where i send you merch and
uh
little notes from me and um it's a lot
of fun it's
family and people come there and they
thank me for
i met my closest friend ever now or i
met my boyfriend or
they become there's all these people who
become these friends on this platform of
patreon
so go to patreon p-a-t-r-e-o-n dot com
slash inside meet new friends
uh support the podcast i'll write a
message to you right after you do it
um also if you want to get any merch go
to the inside of you online store
and um there's lex luthor stuff and
smallville stuff and inside of you stuff
and also the band i gotta throw out the
band uh we're gonna be
performing again may 29th saturday and
put this in your calendars
may 29th saturday two shows 2 p.m
pacific standard time and 6 p.m pacific
standard time
uh we're gonna play some covers and some
left on laurel tunes and some sun spin
tunes my band is sunspin
and um you can go to sunspin.com and
book the band
book zooms uh and you can get a whole
bunch of cool merch
so there's the there's that today's
guest you liked this episode
it was a good one i i like it because
she's so so open and free
and such a wonderful woman inside and
out she talks about her pregnancy and
giving birth
and it was miraculous i was i was
stunned and a little shocked at times
but like
i i just think she's such a wonderful
woman and so smart
and uh she educated me like most people
do
so without further ado why don't we just
jump into it this is a fun episode i
hope you like it
uh let's get into erica christensen it's
my
point of view you're listening to
inside of you with michael rosenbaum
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
erica you look fantastic for someone
who's dating a
who's married to a cyclist and has two
children running around i don't know how
you look so refreshed
thank you i i the kids are a bigger
factor than i think the husband
but uh you know listen it's so weird
it's categorically you not having
children it means that there's
all kinds of things i could say to you
that are completely irrelevant you're
like oh yeah
sleep training and we you know no no
stop talk about sleep training right now
because i i don't sleep well
what do you mean sleep training you
train the children to sleep or you train
yourself to sleep
train the children to sleep but i've
been wondering also how to apply that to
ourselves see the thing is
that in the children what you are
developing as a skill
is going to sleep without dependence
upon
anything without dependence upon you
know the bottle or being rocked or
whatever
the idea is to get them comfortable with
just being in their own bed
when it's nighttime without you and then
they'll go to sleep
um and then staying asleep is a
different thing like staying asleep for
babies is just not getting hungry which
is not a problem for us right
right now how old are the children how
old are the children
two and a half and four and a half so
there's no breastfeeding anymore
there shouldn't be and the two and a
half year old is like
not getting much nutrition probably from
it but she's still
what are you saying what do you mean
there's nothing she's straight up i mean
i mean like my body is not like feeding
the child
she's she's just you know she pacifies
she likes the comfort especially when
it's nighttime
but she can totally talk so she goes i
want a nurse
i'm like uh you can't it's not bedtime
okay wait a minute
because i've said that before but it's a
different kind of nurse
um so so i want a nurse
she wants to nurse from your bosom yeah
oh she straight up says
i love your boobies
okay okay does cole say that did she
learn that from dad
i love yo boo what have you said to you
while you're in bed together i love your
boobies
i love your boys
i love your boobies oh i i don't
know if i'm doing her a disservice or
it does it does uh
what is it there is a bit of a
dependency there and talking about you
know fostering that independence
and that not needing anything to go to
sleep except yourself
she does need that all right so wait a
minute you're teaching her to sleep but
you're not teaching her how to back off
the boobs
i mean i am because no you're right
you just gotta ixnay on the breast nay
yeah
it's got to be how old is she she's two
and a half she's two and a half
okay so i don't know how old you are
when you're supposed to stop
breastfeeding i don't know what the rule
is but i probably
i don't think i breastfed i think uh is
that right breast fed
you were you you were like bottle fed i
was bottle fed enfamil that's why i'm
all effed up
i'm emphamilled up oh
no but what is that it's not not it's
not good you should breastfeed right
is that what you believe ideally yeah
ideally nutritionally it's
it's there for a reason it's awesome if
you can
um i gotta tell you hang on i gotta tell
you that i'm happy no matter how effed
up i am and maybe it was caused by
not breastfeeding but the fact that i
wasn't on my mom's breast
that makes me happy the fact that i
wasn't like the thought of like
like my mother my mouth and my mother's
breast for me
i know it's a natural thing but for me
i'm glad i didn't do it
well that's good then that's pretty good
is it
i mean i don't know you got what you
retroactively got what you wanted
doesn't it hurt
uh not anymore there's like a there's a
period of getting used to it for sure it
can hurt
very badly i didn't cry during
childbirth i cried
i have cried during nursing really like
oh my god you're hurting
me yeah yeah and she's like mommy cry
yeah why you cry you you know why i cry
you don't say it but uh but fortunately
my children don't bite
my children didn't fight so thank god
that's an extra part of it
this is see this is strange this is
this is like a whole category of
conversation
that to parents is normal territory
well like no but it's it's not it's for
me it's like if i ever want to have a
kid i can kind of like
this could either sway me in either
direction i could be like wow
you know i mean look i don't have to
breastfeed but you know
there's a lot to parenting and i think
it's important i think you know we i had
uh
erica durants who was um lois lane on
smallville and she's done a bunch of
other stuff but she talked about
postpartum and stuff and
i'll tell you what so many people wrote
in and were
it just was very important that she
talked about that and what seemed odd
not odd to me but probably maybe a
little weird that a single guy
who has not been married he's asking all
these questions but i do it because i
think it's a real issue and i think it's
like
i had a friend who lost his wife to
postpartum and
and all the things that go on with
raising a child so
i mean did you have any kind of issues
when you first had a baby or was it kind
of smooth sailing are you just like you
just really enjoyed the whole motherhood
or did you have issues
or things that were happening that
you're like i i don't understand why i'm
not happy or i'm
i don't know some people it's easy some
people it's not well it was
i mean of course with as with anything
there's a whole
you know scale there's a spectrum of
experience and
mine was on the easier
side but you can imagine just just
imagine
not getting more than a couple hours of
sleep at a time
for several months you know
it's like it would affect anyone and so
um and learning how to nurse if you're
gonna
do that there it depends for some people
that just come supernaturally and you
know
you're like there you are a cave woman
with your child and
they nurse and everything's wonderful um
but that's definitely like for me that
was a
big learning curve and so
one of the times that i cried when i was
nursing was just because i couldn't
do it like that sounds weird like how
can it just not work but it can just not
work where you just can't get them
to understand your boob and how to get
the milk out and you're just like
come on you know god that seems
frustrating
it's bizarre but then there are people
who are lactation consultants and
they're angels
and lactation consultants
yeah what about um lactation free
consultants i'm sure there are those too
because i have a little problem with the
lactate pediatric
nutrition
[Laughter]
you're supposed to feed your child if
you're not gonna nurse there's
actually there's a whole uh
i mean you know how you said like let's
talk about something controversial
we could talk about politics but um but
what led me to that is there's this
thing where
you know the country has become
so divided and so partisan that
oddly a bunch of ideas and concepts that
philosophies that aren't directly like
i'm in favor of this sort of
bill this sort of legislation and stuff
like that have been
divided and i'll explain further what
i'm talking about what i'm talking about
is
uh i have fed my children and continued
to
raw milk and especially also when i was
having a tough time nursing i was like i
need a backup plan i need some
assistance
my child can't starve while we're
figuring this out
and then also i needed some help when i
was like
working and the baby's still nursing and
so i'm
pumping and we have breast milk but i
also need the raw milk
and then raw milk is just a huge like
it's a huge like like what it gets
categorized
on the side of conservative
like freedom
you know freedom from government
regulation
and i don't understand i don't i'm not
aware of this stuff
i understand ryan are you understand you
know about the stuff good
uh educate because i don't know about
this i didn't know there was a
sort of a divide on raw milk well yeah
because categorically it goes into
the you know natural sort of
um non-medical
non-um mandated vaccines
not it kind of gets lumped over into
this whole side of
governments the government not
controlling what we eat and of course
and what we do to our bodies except for
abortion
that goes on the other side um there's
this weird gerrymandering of ideology
right
but on this side like you have to trace
it back to
okay when i mean do you were you even
aware that milk wasn't raw
uh ryan we weren't aware of that
surprised
right yeah right that's what i always
knew
the milk was pasteurized louis pasteur
invented that
exactly and when louis pasteur invented
it it was for a purpose it was for
killing bacteria
um whatever the the outbreak
was at the time that they were
addressing that was effective
and so great but
we live in a different time now we don't
have the same issues and the people that
produce
unpasteurized milk take great pride in
the safety measures that they take so
that they can provide it to you and
they're not
exposing you to something you know their
cows are very healthy
this seems so random it's not it's
it's interesting it's a big deal because
in traveling about the country
i have you know there are many states
where they
it's just illegal and then there are
many states where you can get it but
it's
labeled it has to be labeled as for pet
consumption only
and so you have to go like talk to the
farmer and go okay can i
can i buy a gallon of milk like we're
not gonna talk about the fact that i'm
gonna drink it and my kids are gonna
drink it and they're like yeah yeah
we're
gonna just just take the milk so who
looks down on you
is it is it the democrats or is it the
republicans i can't understand
it's more it's a it's a liberal side of
like trust the science
louis pasteur did this for a reason you
know
the doctors say it's not safe right so
don't drink raw milk you know the and
and they'll tell
pregnant women don't drink raw milk you
could expose yourself to all kinds of
bacteria and
surely that's true or it was
but if you go to the right farmers that
are are
doing it correctly and healthy and and
organically
it's not it was a problem uh many moons
ago before we uh
okay i got you i'm with you it's not
this isn't weird this is educational you
are educating me and my friend ryan
and i'm glad ryan wasn't like of course
i know this because i would have been
like oh
god i'm an idiot i know it is a little
bit
strange um but i always yeah go ahead
well but like the fact that i'm tying
this to politics at all was obviously
there is legislation against raw milk
which is
so it is a thing but like
you're criminal i'm a criminal no it's
legal in california in
in some ways and so i can get it organic
pastures is the name of the company
they're wonderful they're in northern
california yay
they give me raw milk and raw cheese and
raw butter and raw cream
wow is it delicious it's delicious and
apparently people that are lactose
intolerant
which you are right yeah yeah apparently
they can drink it with no problems
and cheese because yeah because the
enzymes that are that help you digest it
are still
alive they haven't been killed so hang
on
can i come over your house for some
cheese and hopefully not as many farts
oh please i'm not kidding if you're
telling me there's a chance that raw
milk and raw cheese i could eat and not
uh be bloated i
i would try that why wouldn't i try that
ryan cause you might get polio
what polio polio what year is this
what heroin hey you know it's funny
because i don't use the hit word hippie
in a bad way
hippie's a goo i like the word hippie in
fact my dad was a hippie and uh i
believe my uncle and
but you know when i think about you and
cole your husband i think about
just kind of free spirited loving
in the sense of hippie kind of family
like just kind of just like in a good in
a good way
and i can dig it yeah i can dig it i
just kind of feel like you have a
there's a certain lifestyle that you
live and maybe i'm wrong but that is
just
i mean i'm sure there's stress and
there's you know the you know the child
isn't
taking the breast and and there's angst
and but overall
i mean like do you feel like you're like
you have a happy loving
family that's just kind of free and fun
and just like uh that yeah no absolutely
i mean we're very connected to like
nature we take the kids out all the time
to
hikes and and hiking through like you
know up
um do you know angelus crest
up off the two angels crest highway
there's like hikes that you can go to
waterfalls
what how how long are these how long are
these hikes they're they're doable for
at least
the big kid for shane so they're like i
mean you can even get some that are only
like 20 minutes
ooh you'll have to give me directions to
that 20-minute one
these are secret spots you know they
have like swimming holes and jumping
rocks and
we take the kids out to vasquez rocks
well i want to go to these things i'm
going to learn a lot from you
dude they're amazing you should google
vasquez rocks for sure
that's like an hour drive and it's like
you're on mars it's just
incredible terrain and there's not a lot
of people there really no
we've been there during covid and it's
very easy to not
come within 25 feet of a human hey for
someone who's
so you know you're obviously so talented
you've done so much work you've been on
series i mean parenthood lasted for six
years five years yeah
six yeah i mean you've done movies and
this has this bit
been a tough time for someone who you
know loves working
and it's just a weird time anyway it's
like i don't even want to work during
this time i can't imagine being on set
with masks and this
and protocols and tests and i just
rather like let it go let it get done
and let's get back to work
but i don't know how how it's gonna be
what are you are you doing anything
right now have you decided like hey i'm
gonna wait until kind of [ __ ]
gets better or are you like craving to
work
i'm cr i'm yes the ladder i'm craving to
i well having all this time with the
kids has been amazing and at their
ages where they need
you know direct supervision and contact
so much of the time anyway
and we've done all these family
adventures even
i mean and we've also been responsible
we've also you know not left the house
for
large periods of time um but it's been
really fun and i know that i would be
taking it even harder
if i didn't have the kids but i i
want to get back to work you know that
betsy brant lives kind of near us
she was walking by the house yesterday
and she was like
let me tell you when you go back to work
the anxiety will hit you it's going to
be weird you're going to get tested
everybody's wearing you know and then
there's like
wanting to keep your space from people
and then they only do
i think one person in the hair and
makeup trailer at a time which is very
slow socially sad and slow but i
but yeah i want to go back to work i
trust i trust hollywood to do it
responsibly
i just found out from my friend that's
working on um
what's what's ted danse's new show
kramer versus kramer what is it
mr mayor mr mayor what you want to
audition for that
no no my buddy is uh
is pulling focus on then he said they
had to shut down early
but he said the studio is spending a
fortune
on testing and prevention measures like
it's a safe
it's a safe thing you know if anybody
tests positive
anywhere shut down yeah
inside of you is brought to you by
better help better help online
counseling
it's so easy to talk about these guys
because uh
you know the world we live in and even
the world we lived in before
the world we live in is it's always been
stressful people
experience stress and depression and um
loss and you need somebody to talk to
ryan
don't you think it's important to talk
to someone objectively that you don't
know that you could actually
spill your guts and and just breathe a
little bit and get it out of your system
i agree i think that's helpful i i do i
think it's really helpful and you know
people ask
what therapy is and i i'm here to tell
you that therapy is whatever you want it
to be
talking to someone for an hour on the
phone i like to
see the person some people don't like to
see anybody they just want to talk on
the phone
but to be able to get to be able to text
your counselor or facetime your
counselor or just talk on the phone and
counselor and have someone available to
you
at all times is is pretty significant
it's really
time to stop being ashamed of normal
human struggles and start feeling better
because
we all deserve to be happy you you guys
deserve to be happy i deserve to be
happy and that's why i'm working on
myself
um better help is a customized online
therapy that offers video
phone and even live chat sessions with
your therapist
it's much more affordable than um
in-person therapy as i could tell you i
mean you're gonna save
substantially you can start
communicating with your therapist in
under 48 hours
join the millions of people
who are seeing what therapy is really
about it may or may not be for you but
it's certainly
worth looking into because you are your
greatest asset
it's so simple um i urge you to talk to
someone if you're feeling down if you're
feeling like you know
you don't have control of your life this
will change your life
this will help you i know that it's
helped me and i know that therapy has
helped
many many of my friends and i don't know
what i would do without it
this podcast is sponsored by betterhelp
and inside of you listeners get 10
off their first month at betterhelp.com
inside that's betterhelp.com
inside inside of you is brought to you
by ten thousand ten thousand
ryan makes the highest quality best
fitting and most comfortable training
shorts
out there that's how i feel these things
are so comfortable
that i had these old pair of shorts that
i used to wear and i would chafe
and then i noticed i don't want to chafe
chafing sucks
i don't know anyone who wants to chafe
well that's what i'm saying comfort it's
all about comfort when you're working
out you have to be comfortable
and these guys know how to make
comfortable clothing
there are seven intervals short with the
liner and their lightweight shirt
are just fascinating tons of features
like silver ion for odor protection
breathable lightweight shell fabric with
stretch
optional liner that is very comfortable
and prevents chafing like i said
perfect summer shirt lightweight
breathable quick
drying ten thousand is a direct to
consumer company
no middleman so you get premium fabrics
trims techniques
that other brands simply cannot afford
collaborative product development
a team of over 200 athletes test their
gear
to ensure the perfect design fabric
trims and fit at the core of 10 000 our
three
core training shorts built for all the
ways you train
the interval short versatile and great
for spinning
metcons short runs and anything else you
can think of
the foundation short built for
durability for tough gym days and
outdoor adventures
the session short super lightweight
perfect for running yoga
and mobility pick the short that is best
for your training and then personalize
it with custom liner
and inseam options over 500
5 star reviews free shipping and returns
and a lifetime
guarantee 10 000 is offering our
listeners 15
off your purchase just go to 10 000.
cc and enter code inside
to receive fifteen percent off your
purchase that is ten
thousand dot cc and enter code
inside well i wanted to circle back on
the hippie thing because
you are very right in one respect um
last time i did the podcast
i was about to pop with a baby on your
couch
yep you walked up my huge street which
is not easy and you were pregnant
a steep hill and i was very pregnant and
you were worried that i was
my water was gonna break on your couch i
wouldn't know what to do um
my water didn't break either time
actually that's a thing
let's you know what do you mean either
time uh either
either child oh okay either time
either time you walked up here i thought
i'll just talk to you once but but go
ahead
but then i walked back home and
sometime maybe four weeks later or
something like that
i had the baby right and then there are
stories it's kind of generally accepted
that
your second child comes faster than the
first child the labor is shorter right
the bodies because
there's some muscle memory involved and
so forth and so
i went into labor at
like 4 00 a.m
and i figured all right
i'll take some time to myself i stayed
in bed for a while
stayed in bed for an hour and then i
went to the kitchen and made myself a
pour over coffee
for an hour and labored in the kitchen
by myself and then i woke up
cold and we already had planned on
having the baby at home
so we were just like okay everything's
on track we're gonna relax we're gonna
have some breakfast
i called my mom and said don't worry
about it i just went into labor have
some breakfast and come over later
whatever all of a sudden
the baby is coming out of me
basically like i i was like oh my god
i could feel the difference there's a
change there's a whole part of labor
where your body's getting ready to push
the baby out and then there's like
the home stretch which is then your
body's pushing the baby out
and i called the doctor because he was
kind enough to do it
come to my home and i said um i went
into labor a few hours ago the baby's
coming out right now can you come
out and he was like why didn't you call
me earlier i said i didn't know it was
gonna happen this fast
he gets stuck in traffic and cole and i
are completely alone he delivers the
baby himself
right on our bed over there in the peace
and quiet
except for shane is in the living room
watching the lion king not crying going
mommy's crying
no mommy wasn't crying mommy was calm
and quiet and
baby was in the she was watching the
lion king and eating bacon and daddy was
in here
and we didn't say anything we were just
there was a little bit of like
anxiety and tension because we were
waiting for the doctor
and at a certain point we realized
he's not gonna make it he's not gonna
come in time
and then all of a sudden that waiting
just dissipated and that anxiety
dissipated and cole said
one thing he looked at me and said just
so you know i'm not freaking out
i said great and then he
delivered the baby and we are there
hugging her and she's taking her first
little breaths and cries
when the doctor walks into the bedroom
and he's like
so how'd you do and we're like oh he did
great look there's a baby
and then you're like you're not charging
me and of course he is and he's not in
network
well hang on hang on hang on let's go
back so what
because the first thing that happens
when you're telling the story is i feel
joy i feel excited it's an adrenaline
thing
but then i think if it happened to me do
i cut something am i supposed to cut
something
am i what am i supposed to do what do i
do what do i do here
do i have to what do you have to do well
that part cole was about to go
find like a vice grip to clamp the cord
and cut it
but by that time the doctor was there
that part is
um less instinctual so yes
i'm i'm grateful for the doctor for all
of that follow-up what do you have to do
though i mean like can the baby or how
how soon after do you have to cut the
umbilical cord you don't have to cut the
umbilical there's no rush
you're you're even the the you know
natural side of things which i tend to
go in that direction the natural side of
things is
you are to let them stay connected to
the cord
until the bloods or and everything start
stops pumping through it and that could
be 10 minutes
also i just don't think there's any real
is it dangerous if you cut it
just like you cut it is there a right
way to cut it do you
do you get the vice grips do you get a
clean pair of scissors do you kind of
carve it with a butter knife what do you
what do you do there it's not easy to
cut so you need something
sharp for sure and
yeah i imagine you you need to clamp it
but i don't know maybe not let's go back
to the cavemen i don't know
yeah they're like hmm and then they cut
it
yeah they chew on it for a while so that
is back to the hippie thing that is a
little like most people don't do that
and
i by the way if you just did the sound
effects this is what i'd probably hear
at your house okay it'd be like
that's the bacon and then
that's exactly what would happen i mean
i could just sense it
we have one little video
cole set up the gopros to try to film it
and they ran out of battery or whatever
we have
one little video taken on my phone
that's a time lapse of me laboring on
the bed
but there's there's no audio but you can
see me kind of like shifting positions
and breathing and breathing you can't
show me though because you're naked
no i'm uh i'm not actually i think i'm
wearing
clothes at that point can i see it yeah
let me find it
i mean how quickly can i find it so this
happened two and a half years ago
i'll tell you that right so that's
correct
oh yeah i'm wearing shorts and a sports
bra all right let's see it prop it up
so it is ladies and gentlemen it is now
a time lapse of erica
christensen's birth at her house
hippie style jack kerouac style
woodstock style okay
there we go we'll put music over it
breathing heavy i mean it's like the
reflection this is
are you like your arms in the air you're
not stressed you're saying
it's kind of like i'm not you you're
actually in great shape by the way i
noticed that
like a pregnant woman who's just really
in shape stretching kicking her legs
here comes cole i've got this there's
you
and then fast forward a little bit oh
and then there's blackness which i don't
know if my phone
fell oh it fell over that's what
happened my phone was just sitting on
the desk
and it fell over were you just pissed no
i mean yeah
what are you gonna do when you get a
baby in your arms there is definitely
like a bliss that takes over and there's
all kinds of
hormonal reactions the
postpartum thing being a separate thing
there is like
there's your body knows what it's doing
and so a lot of the time
uh it can even just knock my printer
over
um it can even you know block
the nerve channels to to the pain the
baby
blocks off your circulation to so it's a
natural
painkiller right if i was pregnant right
there i would have been jumping off the
walls like help i'm dying there's
something in me get it out
you don't you don't know that i don't
know that but i'm kind of a puss when it
comes to that stuff
it's such a different kind of physical
experience it's like
it's athletic it's an athletic
experience you know it's
an athletic experience i like that yeah
it's they call it labor
you're working your muscles are working
you get
warm you know um and you have to just
if it's that if you're saying it's
athletic and it's labored then why can
so many um
out-of-shape people give birth because
i mean i mean if you need to be athletic
or you need it's a hard labor thing but
like if it's hard i need to get in shape
for this don't i
that's why it's better to be in shape
for it right it is better to be in shape
it does put you
at an advantage so that it's uh an
easier time for you but
um but the the muscles that you're using
you cannot condition
you know so you can condition the rest
of your body but your uterus you're not
going to exercise your uterus any other
time
you can't prep for that so it's it's but
but
i'm saying kind of psychologically if
you can compare it to another experience
that you've had like if
anybody that's like done something that
anybody that's run a marathon
or run run any kind of length of time
that
they put their body through some stress
and they mentally overcame that
and pushed through and just knew like
all right well so i'm gonna be
uncomfortable but
right then it's gonna be over and it's
gonna be worth it and i'm gonna be
proud and happy or whatever you know i i
feel like
i keep expecting you to say like oh yeah
like i do
you lift weights you know it doesn't
always feel good
no i hate it i hate lifting weights but
i know that uh exercise
does help my brain if nothing else it
helps me just the the
anxiety so i assume that as a pregnant
woman
you know when you're giving birth if you
can reduce that anxiety and kind of
relax
it's like i hate to say this but it's
probably like it's not going to surprise
my guest but
it's it's like you know taking a big
poop if you know if you're pushing
you're going to hurt yourself and you're
stressed and it's anxious and
you'll get a hemorrhoid potentially but
like the reality is if you just relax
it's going to be smooth sound and you
could go afterwards call some friends
and say wow that was
i got to tell you about this crap i just
took that's
that's not a crazy analogy okay good
were you glad
when she was out like oh uh
where did you go through that i'm sure
it was well like you said some people
there's a connection right it happened
so fast
it was yeah so it was i mean i was kind
of just like
both times i i was both births right
i was kind of like just amazed
like that there here's there were two
people in a room and now there are three
people in a room
it's just weird it's a very existential
experience yeah you know what's funny is
not funny but i
actually read something a long time ago
that someone recommended husbands
not being in the room and watching the
baby come out because some people
will you'll lose attraction to your wife
i've read that somewhere
no no i'm not kidding they said that if
you watch it
maybe like i'm just saying and i was
like i was like was that true
that sucks because i'd want to see my
child born so you don't think
like but see cole's an anomaly cole's a
man
he's like i love my wife i love my kid i
want to get bloody i want to [ __ ]
grab vice grips i wanna cut this [ __ ]
[ __ ] baby so he's an anomaly so some
men would be like oh my god
her vagina was so big and it was blood
and i can't deal with it
i think it's just like a separate
experience to the rest of your life
it's just nothing matters in that moment
except what's occurring i mean
maybe that's not true if you're just
standing aside and the doctors are all
doing everything and you're like you get
a view over there and you're like oh
look at her body
but you know like god that's gotta hurt
but cole
even the first time when the doctor did
make it in time barely
he was like shoulder to shoulder with
the doctor
and the doctor was like okay you know he
had already said like when the baby
comes out
you can put the baby on on erica's
chest and you can cut the cord and the
whole thing so
cole was like watching the entire time
and as a more of a participant
than an outside observer who's like in
the back of the room being like oh
what's happening with the grossness over
there he's like there's a baby coming
out
like let's focus on what's happening i
think
and then it's and then like i said it's
just like it's such a
separate experience then you go back to
life and then you know
you your wife's body goes back to normal
well i appreciate you
being so open and forthcoming with this
stuff because i think it is educational
for whether a guy or
a female listening who hasn't given
birth or a guy who i mean it's just it's
just kind of inspirational and it's like
the approach that you took and
you know again it's all what works for
you proverbial you
right so i think you know uh some people
i want to be in the hospital
uh the husband's like i don't want to be
around are you cool with that some
people are like want to do it
organically so i want to go to the dairy
farm
and get the raw milk poured all over
them while they're doing it
it just it just depends it's and that's
why it's called freedom do what the [ __ ]
you want this is your world
as much as it is everyone else's and no
one should judge you
for doing what you want to do a thousand
percent which is awesome
we'll go ahead yeah no go well i guess
it's like
hearing hearing my experience would just
be
like if anyone was interested in going
the natural route if
anyone was interested in having a home
birth or having an unmedicated birth
then they could then they could hear
that experience and be like oh okay i'm
going to
file that away as part of my decision
making if somebody's like i want to be
in a hospital whatever
whatever give me the drugs then great
then they can be like well that's
interesting that that's
the way that you did it and good for you
and i'm going to do what i'm going to do
mm-hmm now i knew yeah i knew that i
wanted to do it that way and so i
i watched videos that people
just god blessed them posted to the
internet of them giving birth
wow so i got to watch all these people
give birth and like cry
happy tears for these strangers why
don't you post yours
because i'd have it on video i know
because of the black it fell but that
you could have got a better
camera than your iphone just propping it
up on a desk you could have prepared a
little he prepared so well
he prepared so well for this childbirth
and the relaxation the hakuna matatas
the bacon
the the coal relaxing everything it was
all set in motion and the one thing you
forgot is
the documentation i know the gopros ran
out of batteries or whatever maybe they
didn't have cards and i don't know
are you gonna have another one i don't
know we've been open to the idea
but uh it's
and i come from a family i have three
brothers you know two
two that are twins two that are twins
and one's an actor right
you know one is yes one is more of an
actor than the other one they both have
acted
they they both did a pilot with gavin
o'connor but that was
a million years ago well one did upside
of anger with mike uh
binder who i love exactly who i love as
well
that's dane my brother dane he's a
brilliant actor but i don't know that
he's going to
put much effort into pursuing it right
right he was also
in the movie um it's called all at once
that i made just like five years ago
with a bunch of my friends he auditioned
for this
small role and killed it
and then on set
in the middle of filming the scene
johnny boy do you know johnny abrams
he lives so close to you i know the name
but i don't know him okay so our friend
johnny was an actor and a director
uh he was directing and he
says to dane how about do this taking a
german accent
and dane was like beat beat
okay and he just did the scene in a
freaking german accent like full fledge
that they
used really so i just started doing it
like this like erica this is why i want
to do this to you
like and he started this is what i think
about it and i i don't know
i remember i auditioned for a movie
called u571
about a u-boat and i remember i went in
there and i learned the whole thing in
german i go it's broken
and shriven or there's
nothing and the guy goes you retained it
now yeah and the guy david mossdow the
director goes
uh what are you doing and i go uh
speaking german he goes yeah i know i
want you to say in reading english
and i go i just work two weeks on this
you [ __ ] i literally
had learned this whole speech and all
these things because now i went there so
then i
i didn't really prepare to read in
english so i was like no
do you read or write english do you
speak german
do not speak german do and i ended up
doing it and it was fine but
i wasn't you know like prepared as much
and i worked so hard
i just yeah anyway so what what did you
just say did you say like
lower the periscope i said do you read
spectrums relationship do you read or
write do you speak german do you read or
write it or you're just some simple farm
boy with the name
do you something i remember i don't know
i just remember certain things like that
when something interests me when i
really go oh my god it'd be nice to
learn this or
i can memorize things when i'm really
excited or really want it like i
remember
learning hannibal lecter's um monologue
and silence of the lambs
like you know when he says a sensa once
tried to test me
i hate his lip with some [ __ ] you know
that one everybody knows that one
but i learned the one was like did i
already do this one
oh asian sterling you think you can
dissect me with your blow up little tool
you're so ambitious aren't you but you
know what you look like to me with your
good bad and your cheap shoes
you look like a rogue a wild [ __ ]
hustling the road with a little taste
the magicians came a little info bone
but you really know one more generation
from pure white trash
are you agent sterling that accent you
so desperately tried to share
pure west virginia what was your father
dear was he a coal miner
did he stink the lamb you know quickly
the boys found you
all those tedious sticky fumblings in
the back seats of cars where you could
only dream of getting out
getting anywhere getting all the way to
the fbi
we could cut that right ryan no
i don't know maybe not i don't know i
didn't really do the accent as much but
i remember the dialogue anyway because i
really
loved it i was just enamored by his
performance i was like i want to
memorize this i want to memorize
christopher walken's speech and this i
want to memorize
you know uh oscar schindler and son and
uh you know
uh what's his name um ray finds when he
goes
yeah to cast a spell on you you know
then you evoke looked at my guy do you
see this they have this power
i know ray fine do you do any
impressions they say every actor should
do an impression
you have to have one you don't do one
no i i do my two-year-old that's it let
me hear it let me hear it
that's i i want a nurse i love your
boobies
that's a good one i want i want nurse oh
you're moving
she has an italian accent it's very
weird
inside of you is brought to you by geico
i'll tell you geico's easy ryan it's
easy it is it
it's so easy even a rosenbaum could do
it you know rosenbaum
yeah i heard of him yeah well i'll tell
you what i've been inside of him
inside of you with michael rosenbaum
i've talked to him you know what i'm
saying is podcast
oh yeah listen let me tell you about
geico geico is so easy
we got so much going on in our lives we
got you know
walking the dog we got to go to the
pharmacy we got to go to here there
with geico you don't have to go anywhere
to pay your bills you want to pay your
auto policy
you want to pay your your mortgage they
got a thing called the bundling policy i
tell you ryan
a bundling policy it's so easy that's
right
you just pay one person you don't have
to pay all these people anymore
wow geico makes it easy folks that's
right get a quote all right do it
go to geico.com get a quote
and see how much you could save it's guy
coizzy
visit geico.com today that's geico.com
there's a celebrity here did you see him
inside of you is brought to you by
capsule uh you know how lazy i could be
and not only lazy but i like i like
convenience in my life ryan
and isn't going to the pharmacy one of
the worst things ever
i don't like it standing in line and now
you got the six feet apart so it's like
this long line that wraps around and
people are waiting for their
prescriptions you don't want to be there
you run out of prescriptions you have to
go to the pharmacy
you could pretty much in this world in
this day and age get things delivered
and that's what capsule is about you
don't have to stand
in the lines it's a new kind of pharmacy
capsule they hand deliver your
prescription the same day
for free ryan tell us how capsule
works it's incredibly easy to start
visit capsule.com it only takes 15
seconds to sign up
and when your prescription's ready
capsule will text you to schedule free
delivery at a time you choose
then a capsule courier hand delivers
your medication to your door
straight from their pharmacy in a
tamper-proof package
it's totally secure that's right and if
you uh have any questions you can call
text or email with an expert pharmacist
it's that
freaking simple no more waiting in line
no more driving to the pharmacy no more
forgetting refills
and you know what the best thing about
this ryan it's a way better experience
and capsule doesn't cost
any more than your old pharmacy capsule
accepts all major insurance and is
currently available in new york city and
the surrounding tri-state area
austin boston chicago the twin cities
and
la and other cities are coming soon it's
easy
to sign up visit capsule.com to get your
prescriptions hand delivered
today for free that's capsule.com
hey you know i i really appreciate you
being so open i think i love this it's
just candid talk conversation
and we talked last time about the
scientology stuff and i know you're so
open
and so brave because people would think
you know you get lambasted and people
say oh it's this and it's this
but you stick to your guns this is what
i believe like the raw milk like
whatever
i live a happy existence i'm happy i'm
not judging you why should you judge me
and
you do that and you know i wonder
sometimes like because you're such a
brilliant actress and you've done so
much great work do you think it ever
hinders you from getting roles because
some people are like oh she's a
scientologist we're not hiring her do
you think that happens
i have no idea i have no idea i mean
that would be
that would be wild to me because i don't
know exactly what they would
think i mean it's like it's like
this ephemeral idea that like there's
badness
there like it's it's a trendy thing to
just be like dismissive about it
but other than that like if you truly
have an issue like i don't know
i don't know that's weird well you know
i have a friend
uh my friend john heater i've talked
about this he's a mormon yeah he doesn't
sit there and
preach mormonology to me or mormonism or
whatever he doesn't
you know i love you know they say that
religion
um some people will say religion
organized religion
is really is a terrible thing some
people will say it's the only thing
right this there's the divisiveness
and there shouldn't be because if it
works for you
and you're not telling other people what
to do and how to live their lives
that is a success story when it comes to
religion i have a friend in indiana
who is a christian boy and they go to
church and they
love the lord and that's what they do
and my friend john they go to church
and they have four kids and he's
incredibly family oriented and nothing
really
like uh business-wise uh industry-wise
faze him and he's able to have a really
happy existence
and he's a mormon and this is what he
believes and people will get the
the thing the fundamentalists like well
aren't you a polygamist
he's like no that's what gave us a bad
name those are people that like
that's not us that's like i think it's
the fundamentalist but so are there
you know some people will give you know
all of a sudden one thing will happen
with a scientologist something bad will
happen they'll get accused of something
and it's terrible and then all of a
sudden it brings down the whole the
whole thing
yeah and i think that's like a that's a
symptom
of just not knowing anything about
scientology in general which
they've tried to solve by starting their
own television network so like
let us show you who we are this is what
we believe this is come look at our
churches this is these are the people
that are
doing scientology like there's so much
information just trying to get out there
about like
you don't know anything about us so if
somebody like makes a snide joke
or makes some crazy accusation or
whatever then that's all you know
so it's like getting getting some more
information out there which
i don't know if anybody's taking
advantage of i don't know if anybody's
watching that
what's the show called what's the show
it's an entire
network called the scientology network
that has shows
on all day so look in a nutshell someone
says okay what is it exactly what would
you say
in a sentence or two scientology is an
applied
religious philosophy applied because you
do it you don't just it's not just a
faith religious because it's addressing
you as a spiritual being
and philosophy because it is all of the
questions of life
and why are we here and who are we and
what potentials do we have and how do we
reach them and
what is the purpose of life which is by
the way to help
to help you know to be part of the
entire like
ecosystem of the planet and spiritually
to just to like to be of service as
somebody might say
sounds pretty good that's it but like in
in a nutshell those words applied
religious philosophy
and believing that um
the man is basically good
not that man is basically bad
it's hard it's hard to believe that
lately isn't it
it's kind of hard to believe that in
general uh that you know because
you know for you know whether whatever
you believe out there you know whether
you're a jew or a scientologist or a
mormon or whatever you know
catholic christian hindu we can go on um
sometimes you think well if there is a
god maybe this is his plan to kind of
say hey
[ __ ] sticks why don't you wake up you're
destroying this [ __ ] planet you're
you're killing each other you're
terrible to each other you're you know
and so it's like sort of like a wake-up
call and i think that you know you hope
at the end of this pandemic you hope
people just go
god it's so much easier being nice to
people
isn't that the truth i mean
i mean we noticed at the beginning like
a year ago right at the beginning
that people were being selfish there
were instances where
people were scared about food supply
people
were not fully being respectful of
personal space
and especially during you know when the
kind of first wave of anxiety we still
don't know
very much about this thing just stay the
hell away from me people were like
freaking out but then then
people came to understand how to
be safe and respectful and then it just
came to be
about i think so much about gratitude
for all the essential workers
so much about gratitude for what we do
have
and i know that i mean financially
it's been really rough on so many people
and and
government relief has been kind of
probably insufficient but
but there seems to be a lot of kind of
appreciation for one's fellows well
i i hope we're getting there and by the
way you mentioned a word that i think is
the most important word you said
and it's something that my therapist
constantly right before i go okay
uh good talking to sandy and she's like
gratitudes say your gratitudes
say your gratitude and i'll tell you i
go to bed and i'm if i'm stressed and
whatever and i just close my eyes and i
go i thank my grandmother for freaking
unconditionally loving me
i i thank my you know all of a sudden
and it's better to go it's better to go
to bed with good thoughts in your mind
and it really helps me
it does that's wonderful i could work
that into my
sleep training and for myself that
really eric i'm telling you it's
i'm not the most disciplined guy in the
world but i do just try to when i go to
bed
i lie in bed for a minute and i just
think of everything i'm grateful for
and then somehow i fall asleep and the
next thing i know it's the morning or
sometimes it's four in the morning i go
eat a peanut butter jelly sandwich
that's so beautiful though yeah i mean
cole
will ask the kids you know what was your
favorite part of the day
but to make it broader even than that is
great yeah by the way for the adults
also that's more necessary the kids
naturally go i had a great day and i
love you and you know
that's true i mean yeah but what's the
one thing by the way uh
in terms of scientology that people just
that you hate that people assume
the one thing that just drives you
bananas like why do they
why are they not educated why can't they
ask questions why do they have to assume
this why do they
is there one thing that just drives you
bonkers no and i'm not gonna
rack my brain for it because i don't
even wanna go
there like the simplicity of
of taking ideas that we all can agree on
like gratitude and
and like being responsible for our own
actions
and so forth and so on and
finding a way to achieve some self-worth
you know like
finding being product productive at
a job or if you hate your job and you
know
coaching your kids soccer team or you
know finding ways to be
to be productive and being contributive
all of those things that we can all
agree on that are super simple
you take them and and you find out that
there are
there are actual practical steps and
things that we can learn about our minds
and things that we can do to
make them more effective and not just
ideas and make them into actions and
that's
that's just the simplicity of you know
scientology in general you take like
a book a scientology book
and read that and that's what people
would see if you take
one of my favorites it's called problems
of work the problems of work
this is a universal thing we all have to
do it we all have to work
sometimes it sucks you know so
okay maybe some piece of that can help
you
in that part of your life it's so it's
so
like unassailable
it's so relatable it's so relatable you
know i think that you know ultimately
isn't the idea of religion
or anything to to love love thy neighbor
to
um respect to i mean if you're
look i know you i think you're a
wonderful human being and if you're
doing something
it's not making it's not hurting you
it's only making like you're wonderful
i know you well thank you so so you know
something
has to it works for you and you know so
i i say like
if you're an [ __ ] and you're uh
you're uh whatever religion you are
you're an [ __ ] well but you're
probably working on it that's hopefully
that's the key
that's it you know if you have some kind
of goal for self growth
then good and there are by the way i
might have mentioned this two and a half
years ago when we talked about it before
but
there are i'm not sure i can't
say for sure that there are mormon
scientologists but i know for sure that
there are
plenty of jewish scientologists plenty
of nation of islam
who practice dianetics and scientology
plenty of
baptist you know so forth and so on
because it's not
it's not a faith it's just a practice
it's not a
it's just tools to help you achieve
those things
right whether you want to call it some
some peace
whether you want to call it being a
better person if you know you're an
[ __ ]
you know if you've got a temper or
whatever or if
whatever it is achieving brotherhood
with the universe
great then here's some truth so that's
all
if you have a problem if you have a
problem you can go to the scientology
they have areas where you're like i have
a problem with my marriage i have a
problem with
this you can go and get help right away
and you don't have to necessarily go to
a therapist or you have is that a
separate thing
no you can go and get help right away
and and
the thing with uh the thing that kind of
i think is the main differentiation
between
seeing a therapist about it and seeing a
scientology counselor about it
is that the scientology counselor won't
um interpret anything for you won't
tell you what to think about your
situation won't tell you
what you're doing wrong they'll just ask
you the questions that give you the
opportunity to take responsibility
and to help you see the way that things
are in a marriage
that's like that is the key thing is any
any dishonesty and i don't straight up
mean lies i just mean
lack of communication that's there that
kind of dishonesty
um keeping secrets it's like all right
now out with them all i don't know what
they are it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter
you you just have to get them all out
and then you're gonna have to work
through that stuff
but the the linchpin of that working
is getting all of those secrets out
anything even if it's like
you know i spent too much money on your
christmas present and then now we've got
this debt on the
amex or you know like stupid things
that you just keep secrets from each
other and that's
that's where you have problems i think
that's the sign of a good therapist
anyway
one that asks questions and doesn't give
you answers because all the answers you
know the answers you need to be asked
them so you can adjust and make the
right choices
and make the right changes because if
you're just asking for
oh here's the answer go lose weight oh
okay i already know that yeah well why
aren't you losing weight or
why aren't you acting a certain way oh
because you're not putting the effort or
because you don't why don't you love
yourself
okay because i did this okay well don't
do that there's just
like i it's such a cyclical thing that
we go through that in therapy that it's
just like you know
we know what to do sometimes we don't
sometimes
you know i needed a little bit of uh
something
to to sort of help me and you know
that's okay it's like sort of
uh anyway but look i look i love that
you
i love that you're just so passionate
about it and so brave and i really think
that if you
you know wish more people could be like
that in terms of anything they believe
in
because this this it's sort of the
shitstorm in the past
x amount of years where now having a
belief about something you get lambasted
for anything
and so you have to be really careful
other than making a fart joke online i
kind of
shut up because i know i'm gonna put my
foot in my mouth i say something all of
a sudden you're up on following you i'm
like i don't mean it i'm not a bad
person well that's the thing that's the
flip side of it is we all have to be
willing to hear each other
that's what's so rough is like you can't
make assumptions about
about what someone's belief
means about the rest of them i know
you're right and it
it does get sort of convoluted and tough
because
i i don't talk politics i just don't do
it on this show because i think it's
like you know there's so many things
people shows that people talk politics
but i could i could easily talk about
things
and ryan's like don't do it don't do it
don't [ __ ] do it we can talk about
philosophy the underlying philosophies
not about not about seeing not about the
people that we expect
to represent them in the government
but you know what they are what we are
hoping that they represent and the
actions that they take based upon the
ideas that we hold
that's a separate thing you know just
have a conscience that's all i want
people to do is have a effing
conscience when you're thinking about
what people are doing
have a conscience imagine you are being
that person that's being oppressed or
being whatever it is
just in life if you just put yourself in
their shoes for a second
your perspective will change this is
called [ __ ] talking with erica
christensen fans
from my patron uh you can join patreon
patreon.com inside of you these are
questions just for you there's
rapid fire if you want here we go wait
oh my god okay yes go go go
i'm ready all right leanne p of all the
roles you've played which one do you
identify with the most
oh my gosh well i
i do probably
more julia in me now than when i played
her
but now more julia braverman graham from
from parenthood
awesome ray h race harada what are you
doing to stay mentally healthy
um working always on improving myself
as an individual and getting outdoors
and by the way are using the echelon uh
treadmill
i meant to bring that up yes thank you
so much i did a ride this morning
how great is it it's really amazing
it's really amazing for it's like a new
toy
still i got it election day it arrived
november 3rd it showed up on my doorstep
it was extremely heavy but we set it up
and i
think i waited till the next day before
i actually got on it but it's still a
new toy
i love it like i see it and i'm like
well what am i not going to ride it it's
just sitting right there
get on it and you got that monitor and
you could just feel like you're part of
something and just
see i i have 80d so i need to monitor i
can't just go oh i'm going to be on a
stationary bike i need to
watch something no well i've just done
it where you're like watching
just watching a movie on youtube i gotta
beat herb and
i gotta pass sandy and i gotta be in you
know i gotta see how far i can get
otherwise yeah i gotta be competitive
when i'm doing it i got
dropped today some people really kicked
my
butt doing what exercising riding the
bike
yeah riding the bike right now i was
like
damn these people just put me to shame
this morning
i like it but so what are you doing
mentally healthy i guess you're doing
that right
yep well actually we can we can make
getting outside and exercise
separate things because they're not
because exercising inside is also
super helpful and wonderful but yeah
getting outside
literally seeing the sky and getting
some fresh air and sunshine in your
lungs
is is really helpful
and then also you know working on myself
nico p what's some of the best feedback
you've ever received
the one thing that you remember someone
going god
swim fan you were just or traffic
you are the best actress ever oh
parenthood your role
julia gulia you were amazing what what
is it what's the what's the one
that you remember that really you
remember going oh that felt good
could be from someone you admire some
from your dad
from cole oh from cole
the best feedback he's ever given me is
that when he's watching
me in something that he forgets that
it's me
best thing you could say to an actor
the worst thing you could say is like i
can't i can't just i can't take you
seriously
it is you it's you being weird frozen
mom you're
what's your biggest guilty pleasure in
life in life
in life in life
i mean this is this is funny
but what my mind went to was instagram
because it's like it's just like reading
a magazine i use it for
genuine inspiration i see all those
people getting fit out there and
being organized and all those things and
cooking beautiful meals so i love
all of it but it's also like if i'm
procrastinating
i will be on instagram i know that i'll
be like okay
put it down lisa h what's your favorite
storyline
on parenthood
uh
[Music]
well i mean mine
[Laughter]
trying to conceive and then the whole
adoption process being long and arduous
and
that's also relatable to so many people
and i'm
grateful that i was able to address that
mary b
last question what life lessons have you
learned during the coveted crisis in the
whole 2020 experience that you want to
you
want to be sure to teach to your little
girls
oh wow what a great question
well um
[Music]
an interesting thing about
the pandemic is that i think it has
brought to the forefront of our
attention how we are responsible for our
community
because it's directly you know it's
directly
we are directly responsible for others
in our environment you know um
and it took something like this like you
know you don't want to get your
neighbors
sick and you don't want them dying to
put that into perspective you know
the the the respect and the joyfulness
that we treat each other also
spreads everywhere
and so that's an important thing and
then also
um this is a little bit
hopefully i can express this but
basically
being responsible for your own life as
much as you can
i know so many entrepreneurs
that have had a really rough time
the last year and i just respect
those people so much for pivoting
or figuring it out for finding ways that
they can
continue to scratch their creative itch
or whatever but basically like you know
not
taking it back taking the ownership back
on your your own life
from wherever it may have gone for if it
has gone to your significant other or
your job or
i like that it's more about being aware
of other people and what they're going
through
and i think it's just a lot of different
things i mean it's it's a heart
for me it's just really respect like you
know like i don't have little girls but
what i'll tell my two little dogs who
one
just came in the room and sitting here
the old guy is 12 and a half
he just he never comes in here like that
he just came in here and sat with me and
wants to sit with me and i'm like
you know i don't know how long i have
with this little sucker and he's like
he's old and he's you know it's just
like
i told him i said i looked at him one
day i said you tell me when you're done
man
and we'll be done together but if you as
long as you're not in pain
and as long as you're still eating and
laughing and playing with a little girl
little little uh
my little pup yeah as long as you want
to be here i want to have you here
i'm not going to be selfish about it so
uh you know because it's easy to be
selfish and like you know he's gone
blind twice and
my friend harland he so funny
harlan will go williams yeah he he's
yeah
he is it's unbelievable like i'll go
yeah you know irv uh went blind
i said buddy you know maybe it's time to
put him down i go
what no he just went blind they're
working on getting his sight back he's
on pills
well buddy i'm just saying you know
irv's uh hey earth stubbed his toe yeah
maybe it's time to put him down bud
no he stubbed his toe what are you doing
you know or how's er doing is it time no
you've been saying this for eight years
it's not time
uh but i love them and unconditional
love is the most important thing in the
world
it absolutely is here here well listen
uh i hope you had fun because this was
to me this was honestly i know you're
gonna probably go
back to uh cole and say it was just
weird we talked about
breastfeeding and i'm telling you this
is fun this is like this is real
conversation
and just candid talk and i learn so much
i really
i know that i don't have to cut the
umbilical cord right away i learned that
natural childbirth could be great i
learned that raw milk i might not be
farting and bloated if i have raw milk i
should try it there's a lot of things i
learned hikes i am this is an hour of
therapy for me
i'm so glad i could be of service yes
and i can't wait to actually hang with
you
i know man i don't know when that will
be but i will disinfect
a package of raw cheese and leave it on
your doorstep really and there's no real
there's no real risk of meat eating it i
mean i
don't think so but as long as you're
getting it from that farm i'll try
what's the worst thing that could happen
yeah so you get some tooth [ __ ] my pants
come on
erica thank you for allowing me to be
inside of you again i i really love this
i
truly love this and i expect to get some
text from you
oh you got it it's coming uh yeah i i
have notes here we're going to talk soon
all right love everybody all my love to
the family too thank you
bye bye
well i hope you enjoyed that and there
was a little nugget in there
my little nugget uh irv irv showed up in
the podcast it was i think the only time
he ever appeared in the podcast
yeah oof i'll get emotional just
thinking about it
uh i miss him and that this podcast was
recorded
probably back in january or february so
um
he just came into the room and i was
like there there he is um
[Music]
yeah i do miss the guy people have been
sending me gifts and
pictures of irv and i've got like this
whole shrine of him
so it's really nice so i don't want to
continue to talk about irv although i
will because i love him and he's my son
damn it and i will miss him
uh but thank you for all the comments um
13 years is a long time to have a dog
and he lived a good life and
uh i hope to see him again someday
um again thanks erica christensen for
being so open i hope you guys enjoyed
that podcast
and again subscribe to the podcast you
can subscribe on youtube you subscribe
on apple all this stuff you could listen
and watch and enjoy
um again you could join patreon
patreon.com
inside um the inside of your online
store for merch
thesunspin.com for merch and and booking
us for zooms and things
and um we really appreciate i appreciate
all the patrons out there who um
support the show ongoing it's just
amazing and so many great messages and
comments and i do i do sometimes i
respond
but a lot of times i just read them and
i don't respond next week we've got a
really fantastic episode
another fantastic episode he might be in
the room
yes that somewhere
is freddy krueger robert england
yup if you are still listening you just
heard it it's
awesome and he's one of my i love uh i
love the nightmare elm street
movies he's a great guy he has so much
information this is a really great
episode
so make sure you tune in next week for
robert england freddy krueger
um nightmare and elm streets uh i think
you're gonna really enjoy it we worked
together in a movie called urban legend
and uh that was a lot of fun ryan
anything else
no just waiting on my second vax that's
all
oh yeah i noticed at the movie you were
still you're backed off a little bit
still you weren't so
yeah yeah you were kind of like still
weird i'm just trying to i don't know
you're weird around people right now i'm
weird around i'm weird about people
anyway but you know i'm weird around
people even more now
uh yeah i'm just i don't know i'm just
trying to like not get it before i get
my second dose to get my second dose in
a
week all right so i think he'll be okay
i'll be i mean i'm not worried about you
i think you're gonna be fine but you
know it's good to be a little cautious i
wish more people were cautious i don't
think we
went through the hell we were in if
people were just a tad more cautious but
let's get into uh
all the patron love i have to at the end
of every episode i always uh
give a shout out to all the patrons so
bear with me and if uh if you're done
listening
i understand but these are my lovable
patrons and uh join patreon and you'll
get your name shouted out as well
nancy d mary e
leah f s [ __ ] trisha f
there we go cerave little lisa you kiko
jill e
brian h lauren g nico p robin s jerry w
robert b jason w apothian christine k
amelia o allison l just j lucas m raj
c joshua d emily s c j
p samantha m jennifer n jackie p stacy l
maybe a baseball announcer carly h
here's the pitch on the way to carly s
jen s
and left field jamal f janelle b and
wright
here's the pitch to carrie b tab of the
272 it's a line drive to right field
ashley ryan picks it up
throws over to kimberly e mikey is now
up to bat mikey is friends with marissa
n and eldon supremo is on deck
99 more in ramira diego m
sarah f chad w leanne p ray a
maya p is the lineup for today's ball
game this game brought to you by
aisha my asian c
maddie s kendrick f ashley e shannon d
matt w belinda and kevin v james r
robert maybe we do one as uh ronnie
danger hey chris h
osborne ashborne hey i was born before
you
all right how are you osborne i sent you
a package you still have
the package got sent back give me your
right address williagborn
dave h samantha s spiderman chase
sheila g rey h
i'll tell you what do this voicemail
you've been doing great i'll tell you
that
tab of the team misha h tom n
suzanne b kdf liliana a
michelle k hannah b who's that
hannah b michael s talia m luke h
andrew t betsy oh claire baby
that was my space he didn't sound like
him oh just sounded like bored to you
board who's this liz g
though jay malkovich that's malkovich
that's correct
laura l chad l
rochelle nathan e brandel taylor k
neil a marion meg k janelle p trav l
dan l jennifer j wayne m diane r ojeda
lorraine g augustine corey m carey h
veronica k big stevie w kendall teague
lindsay m
carol d kdg sandy b angel m eriksee
rhiannon rhiannon rings like a bell
through the night and
wouldn't you love to love her
stephen m corey k super sam sherry s
and coleman g are my lovable top tier
patrons
i love you all if i blitzed over your
name i can't spend that much time it's
just me
riffing uh this has been uh
really nice i hope you enjoyed the
episode continue to listen
please continue to support i love doing
it and i will continue to do it as long
as you guys are
loving it so spread the word if every
one of you just sent an email to all
your friends and
asked them to please subscribe that
would be wonderful
from myself michael rosenbaum along with
for myself
ryan tatus i was trying the writing day
hey here in the hollywood
the hollywood it comes from your chest
it comes from my chest i'm not
sitting up here you got to sit up right
right well for me ryan tayz
yes in the hollywood hills of california
look in the camera there we are
we love you guys thank you so much for
allowing me to be inside of each and
every one of you today
and i hope you have a gorgeous week and
be good to yourself love yourself
and be good to others all right see ya